quand je le sens je sois camille quand
je vois tes yeux
ainsi je suis amoureux est ce que je
fais quand tu marches comme un chat tu
voudrais alors on a quelques amis tout
de suite mais
[Applaudissements]
alors on a le rythme on a le groove tu
te bats je peux pas de toi scared club
[Applaudissements]
d'amis qui fait son retour et y aura
aura deux fois plus de camille ce soir
il va bien maintenant et viendra bien
sûr à 20h50 en fin d'émission c'est
camille combal au carré bim bimbadaboum
et toi là que j'arrive c'est pour toi là
que je l'aimais et je me fous badji là
que j'te pousse d'accord il a passé deux
jours avec moi voilà alors combien je
peux vous dire la vérité
c'est ici il n'est pas dans les
émissions puis en afrique générant loge
bien des boyaux ya la vérité parce qu'on
vous dit où il tournait les émissions
mais camille voilà il est à découvrir à
il est en loge idée code met en
confiance avant l'émission mais c'est
moi en fait centre de grigris la
bienséance wade
drapeau tout cas me canis et ma patte de
lapin
voilà la jolie et il était là et en
loges ont déconné avant l'émission
voilà tranquille et voilà il trouva dans
la lumière puisse rentrer chez moi alors
on me l'a fait après la pub
l'acupuncture a tant mieux ouais ça va
bien du côté sale away et là c'est un
peu tendu
les gens qui me disent ah voilà c'est
les soucis on est en bas moi je pars
mais camille combal reste l'émission
continue bon allez je dois partir sur
c'est pour nous c'est cadeau la clôture
avec moi et si l'autre partie
[Applaudissements]
est pas là on fait ce qu'on veut le
pendant du perrier me le mettre sur la
tête je veux faire du sud
je tends du formidable les avis et
andrew dire bonsoir j'ai essayé là que
quelques minutes merci a évidemment tous
les chroniqueurs tout le public était là
vous tous devant voter
cyril évidemment sera de rencontrer dit
à sa place et c'est parce qu'il est en
direct tout de suite
c'est cadeau
j'ai toujours rêvé de faire la télé ce
que dollar
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]